here's a great little question that's
been sent in by a viewer which is
given this little clue x equals e to the
power of log x
find this integral okay now it does look
really difficult
2 to the power of log x you think how do
i even start with this
but the coup they've given us is all
that we need okay now the question is
how are you going to use it you can see
you've got e to the power of log
x and there's a something the power of
log x there so you wonder
i wonder if that log x and that log x
are related but you're going to find
far more useful to think of x equals e
to the log x
in the case where x is equal to 2.
that'll give us 2 equals e to the power
of log
2. okay now let's think about that and
see how we can use it here
okay if i make that substitution instead
of 2
i'm going to write e to the power of log
2 now that's just 2 so
that whole thing there is raised to the
power log x
and that's what i'm integrating with
respect to x okay great
now because of my index laws here right
if you have a to the power of
m raise that to the power n that's the
same as a to the power of
m times m okay so these two powers
up here i can just multiply them right
i'm going to get the integral of e to
the power of log
to log x with respect to x
okay now this doesn't look any better
than when we started okay i'll admit
that
but if you think about your log laws
in particular what's going on up here
just forget about this e for a minute
okay
if you think about log 2 times log x log
2 is just a number
it's just a constant right so if you had
say
2 log x if you you might remember that
your index laws will tell you
that 2 can move up into the index
of what you're taking the log of so that
too can move up the front
rather up the back in the corner there
it'll be log of x squared there
the log laws will take care of that now
they're not exactly the same thing
because
this is an even function and this is not
but the log laws in terms of the value
will hold okay
so if we consider that up here right
instead of 2
log x i've got log 2 of log x and log 2
is just a number okay so therefore i can
move it up into
the power here all right so i'm going to
rewrite this now
it'll look like this e to the power of
log x to the power of log
2 integrating with respect to x
now that's a bit confusing you've got
powers of powers
that looks like it's much worse than
where we started but it's actually much
better because think about this
this now is in the form of what we had
at the beginning that clue
x equals e to the log x if you say e to
the log
something you'll just get something okay
well i've got e to the power of log
something it's just that something
happens to be x
log 2. so therefore this x to the power
of log 2 rather
so therefore this whole thing is just x
to the power of log
2 with respect to x
really yeah absolutely think about what
this means
and how it relates to this okay now this
is much easier to work with
than this and it might not seem
intuitive that those two are equal but
they are you can test out values and see
what happens okay
this is just x raised to a constant
power
okay and so this is just like this is
this is an
x to the n kind of situation right when
you integrate that you're just going to
have
um you raise the power by one and then
you divide by the new power okay so
that's exactly what i'm going to do
that's going to become raised the power
to 1 plus 1 okay and then you divide by
the new power and then you add your
constant integration of course
so there you go um i've done i've
integrated it okay
now if you wanted to you could um you
could take that line and you could go
home
that's that's fine however if you want
to make it just a little bit
simpler well it's not really simpler but
it's closer to what you started with
this function you
were asked to integrate you can just
rearrange this slightly
notice that when you've got something to
the power of something plus
1 right that plus 1 is shorthand for
multiplied by
x again so i've got x times x log
2 and that's just index laws there okay
and you've got your denominator there
plus your constant okay but x to the
power of log 2
x to the power of log 2 is the same as 2
to the power of log x which is what you
started with
right so another way to write this is x
times
2 to the log x all on
log 2 plus 1 plus my constant
okay so you could either take
this line here which was after
integrating okay and i think that would
be fine
or for bonus points not really for bonus
points i think it's equivalent really
you could simplify it back to that the
only reason why you'd like to write it
like this is because your 2 to the power
of log x there
is just like the 2 to the log x that you
started with and that's how you approach
this question